absolutists truck that was in their
backline go or legislature own right
take cuckoo is off the hunt Easter rearm
get closer get the heckler on the magnet
support is there example get the dock
doubles up the rain stop in time Randy
flies back to you for a drop there's
will people walk kills on the back of
that horse tipped at the man on the run
he's going to roll in balls down over
the hill and he's either way I cannot
believe in his decision right now that
was so crucial all my god what have
players he just saved the game right
there I think my they baited out the
spectre-5 and they didn't Emily from
credible
orchids growl uncontrollable around both
the quelling blade in his backpack you
saw no way to come from the tree these
things around it will get the job the
company doesn't matter
[ __ ] this office or with these jars oh
dear just beautifully get you straight
the silences double fillers through the
liquid and it's going to be a 4 5 9 c
wash with it for the damage is being
done the t three periscopes won't care
from a spirograph and all this the army
is the only bubble you'll remain
embedded a real okay the mail get pulled
out yummy tiny was highlighted so it's
actually such a big defensive play by eg
seems like mission important but and the
possible that he knows do it we are
glorious by Raven Ferguson Boston and
PSC they stop their process they kill
will arrive they the business by ground
posture actually going in with lilz
oblique crosses because he's what's
happening I got a good the army there is
more here when the Queen damn it C&C the
Lori's practically everything and that
is you
no one can live big on that
drop they get the pill quick and now
they need to get out just as
progressives coming in not able to
finish them often times they do gather
retreat successfully put some pitch
getting flipped on the way out that's
why there we've been forward tending to
balancing it is a good tornado on it
well you want to get out he will click
play my Abed make the panel hope I've
ever seen a tornado people have three
girls Oh spreadable
this is a very very good mission by
Piemonte Great Pacific I know you can
take three yeah that is not a tree you
you will notice all the world knows it
you know it takes it takes a monkey
player to find that tree so of course
over go find it the master is still the
master now they've got them on the run
they damage the one they came forward
party Gator but now the combo thank you
senex or absolute destruction bgk made
the door slam shut and cut them off at
that
they blame why is going to show himself
immediately going to be pounced on and
shouldn't have much and here quickly to
slide if you're the kill napping dental
River and Night Stalker on their way
they're very mobile heroes been and
marketers are out he met you know green
and ot with no follow on from Anna's are
going to be able to take all these pills
at for club days big-time men three
heroes and a black hole at seven men and
that's just amazing
seems like a combat acknowledge even
more if there's like a good manova like
you get away from the corner and you're
my that filled all the done it he's past
the Atheist and analyse Ali's chose
proof of the crystal Nova TSP folio
Shadowhawk they know it was a
neighborhood they've got to break the
link if he's already jumped down to the
low ground they still pursue maybe will
available things there goes that didn't
BKB in time for has he he tries to get
away he popped it be surprised
and now the Turner over after multi on I
comes in looking for the rescue trying
to bring out desert to get drugs more
commitment and the epicenters coming
look for the follow from table oh he's
don't get walked down for a moment
under the sandstorm but he seems alive
HSN pre engaging you called it full HP
and now looking for bid one to it's
early and Fokker splashes into pit serve
back for the timber both tonight for you
sir
and I'm just looking at the EGS and I
feel like these cases maybe they're
coming home eg is coming face mark up as
you will go inside the penalty converged
on a lot of my back I'll be able to do
another one ten days before brain this
could be a disaster in the pen
vivillon song thank you know life is
impossible tagging all come down the
only person he will go down please give
me back to help us but now if you reveal
the position eg they caught the winning
moment the final version of headed back
in this one of us be a fascist is really
for all the easy fans
that teamfights melted hesitated and
decided the male with balls of steel
cars he catches SG in the pit slide to
speak up a double down conversion
however this may work for their
advantage to blink down here comes the
tornado passing on the crew from a man a
green golden cow here's my calls darlin
he actually go berry picking those up
and began with my call go yourself
do they have enough of it you are losing
the rubix is indeed coming out on top
you bundle up a day later well Dee's
just hit da bars are genius they're
leaving Burak
he found a target the we've actually
gave a little bit vision but he wants a
punch into Randy's hearing doesn't
actually get the match ever concocted
preparing the rock with a better one
will connect now you'll Center the
keeping early on the fight and a big
road there holding a man but the damn it
you'll drop the hammer bit of back again
is still doing it works Martel this
imbecile beat the man doing the damage
until Anna those a lockdown you actually
have a fight going away or jail but I
just learned how to damaged propeller G
butter perk all's JJ purging will be
claimed full time a soda third major
winners here in Kiev thanks for watching
if you want more great content be sure
to hit that subscribe button
[Music]